So this is a super interesting story that
is getting a lot of attention in the last
24 hours.
I was even on rising this morning talking
about this with crystal ball and cigar and
jetty and the story is that how speaker Nancy
Pelosi, of course, a Democrat said yesterday
that she would be comfortable with Bernie
Sanders as the democratic presidential nominee
if indeed he ends up being the selection of
the democratic primary voters in what's left
of this 2020 democratic primary.
And she was asked this just as she was walking
out of a meeting of the house of representatives
and she simply said yes, answering the question.
Yes she would be comfortable.
And this is interesting for a few different
reasons and before we go on with the discussion,
also note that Senate minority leader, Chuck
Schumer was asked a similar question and he
sort of seemed to be saying the same thing.
He said, quote, look, the bottom line is very
simple.
We have a lot of strong nominees and I'm not
supporting one over the other, but I think
every one of them will be a will beat president
Trump or would be better than president Trump.
So not a ringing endorsement, but certainly
both Schumer and Pelosi, the democratic leaders
in the respective house, Senate and house
are saying they would at least be okay with
a Bernie Sanders nomination.
So there's a few different angles here to
talk about.
First of all is okay.
I mean they, they recognize that Bernie of
all the candidates has the clearest path to
the nomination.
It's certainly clearer than any other individual
candidate right now.
And so they're just getting in line.
This is a relatively cynical interpretation,
but I think one that is not a irrationally
cynical, they want to be on the inside, not
the outside.
If Bernie Sanders ends up as the nominee.
And in particular, if Bernie Sanders ends
up being president.
So in one sense you could say, we don't really
have to pay much attention to Pelosi and Schumer
saying this because it is a cynical, strategic
decision of the centrist establishment Democrats,
uh, to make sure that they don't end up getting
the door shut on them.
If Bernie Sanders becomes nominee or president.
And that's obviously part of it.
There is no question that they don't want
to be on the outside if Bernie's the nominee.
But there's a very important secondary implication
here.
Uh, if you look at the five 38 odds right
now, there are roughly equal odds of Bernie
securing the nomination before the DNC with
1,991 delegates or more and roughly equal
odds of there being nobody who gets to 50%
plus one.
If there is nobody who gets to 50% plus one
delegates before the DNC, the democratic establishment
is going to need to decide whether they want
to contest the convention and try to deny
Bernie Sanders the nomination either through
the Alliance of the delegates of various centers,
candidates or with the addition of the superdelegates
on the second round of voting who could just
hand the nomination to somebody else.
So the importance of Nancy Pelosi and Schumer
signaling, or at least though Kay, with a
Bernie nomination, maybe a sign that the democratic
establishment is not going to try to contest
or broker the convention in order to deny
Bernie the nomination, even if he has a plurality
of the delegates.
That in and of itself is a crucial decision
because that could have a huge effect on the
general election.
It is conceivable that if the democratic party
is seen as heavy handed and going out of their
way to deny the nomination to the person with
the most delegates, if that person is indeed
Bernie Sanders, there is a risk that that
is going to reduce turnout in November and
help Donald Trump win.
It is a risk that it will turn some democratic
voters who support Bernie Sanders in the primary
away from voting at all in November or even
towards writing somebody in third party, uh,
to voting for Donald Trump even.
And when you start to see party leaders saying
things like Nancy Pelosi saying, I'd be comfortable
with Bernie as the nominee.
This could be a very important sign that they
recognize that it could be a self-destructive
action to take the nomination from Bernie
Sanders or to be seen as doing that even if
it's not in practice.
What you believe is going on now at the same
time, uh, could it, this could be something
that is being said by Pelosi and Schumer to
make us think they won't contest the convention
when in fact they plan to.
But that's sort of like two layers of cynicism.
Maybe it's too much cynicism.
There's also a potential lesson here from
Republicans in 2016 because when you think
back to the Republican primary in 2016 remember
that for a whole bunch of that primary, the
full Republican establishment, including Fox
news and a lot of right wing media, they were
United against Donald Trump instead of with
Donald Trump.
Now they ultimately came around to him because
anything was better than Hillary in their
eyes.
And Donald Trump ended out just barely squeaking
out an electoral college victory because of
about 77,000 votes in three key States.
It's not crazy to think that if the DNC were
to simply rally behind whoever is the nominee,
uh, and even behind whoever is looking like
they have the best shot at being the nominee,
which right now is Bernie.
They might be saying, even if we don't like
Bernie, even if we're not actually comfortable
with Bernie as the nominee, if Republicans
were able to get Trump elected even after
being against them almost all the primary
and coming to him at the end, maybe our best
shot at removing Trump is just getting behind
whoever is the nominee, regardless of whether
they are from what they perceive to be a different
wing of the left or the democratic party.
In the end, it's important that Nancy Pelosi
is even willing to say this at this point
in time, even if it's completely cynical,
even if it's completely self-serving and out
of her motivation, not to end up on the outside
of the democratic party.
If indeed Bernie Sanders becomes the nominee
or president, it is still important that she's
saying this at this point in time.
If you have a different interpretation of
what Pelosi and Schumer signaling, at least
acquiescing to the idea of a Bernie Sanders
candidacy, let me know.
I do want to hear from you.